une fumée âcre difficilement respirable
voilà ce que les habitants du quartier
de planoise ont vécu toute la journée
sous leurs pieds
un brasier qui n'en finit pas de se
consumer des dizaines de voitures qui
s'enflamme les unes après les autres
tout a commencé vers 9h ce matin trois
hommes masqués et armés font irruption
dans la fourrière municipale
ils incendient un véhicule sans doute
une pièce à conviction pour la justice
manifestement il ya un geste qui
pourrait être criminelle puisque des
individus se sont présentés avec un
bidon d'essence à la main et donc l'
enquête déterminera maintenant si si le
lien est direct et c'est effectivement
un geste criminel
en quelques minutes le feu s'empare du
parking souterrain
très vite les fumées envahissent le
supermarché situé juste au dessus
trois cents personnes des clients sont
évacuées d'un magasin tout fumé et
rentrer dans le magasin il ya plus on
voit plus rien il ya tout et futurs en
fait d'intermarché et été évacuée il n'y
a pas de n'y a pas de victimes ni
problèmes personnels il parlait
des acheteurs le client donc on est en
train d'évaluer la situation en fin
d'après midi les pompiers entamaient des
mesures de toxicité des fumées dans ce
quartier qui abrite près de 20000
habitants ça 50 cd grosse valeur mais
c'est pas c'est pas significatif pour
beaucoup le coeur n'était évidemment
plus à la fête
c'est quand même incroyable quoi que ce
soit à 31 décembre que ça arrive comme
ça à 31 décembre au matin
ça pourrit à huile de tous ces gens qui
pensaient faire un bon réveillant ce
soir les pompiers n'ont toujours pas
atteint le centre du brasier
ils redoutent la propagation du feu dans
ce parking de plusieurs milliers de
mètres carrés des pompiers qui s'apprête
à lutter toute la nuit encore